I want to talk about what the happened to our TV show. Uh,
Oh Jesus, here we go. Here we go. What we,
you and I go to every network, right?
Do we on Hollywood? No, no, no, we don't on it. We're not on it,
but you and okay.
Well then why do we see shows that shouldn't even stand a chance against you?
And I get on, why are we having such a hard time selling?
We have so much power behind us saying that, that it should be on. I know.
So you and I go with, what is it with Howie Mendell, right. And we go to,
I'm going to give any names, but yeah, who's a friend. He's not like a enemy.
Well, I just don't want people like out there to be like, Oh, they're dropping.
I was just saying, dropping anything. I'm just at this Dean.
And I'm not seeing that people, I don't want to call anybody out. Like,
like yeah. We walked into the room with a lot of power. Yeah. Alright.
So we, and we have our agencies behind us. We think we have a good idea.
And um, I think don't say I know and we, and we've done it. We've done it.
We've done it. We did it seven years ago too. Yeah.
And they still know it's been a part of our life. And then we thought,
we thought, you know,
him and I are growing in our own different ways in terms of the business and
whatnot. And in our audiences and stuff,
we thought that combined you and I share some audience, but we have different,
you know, audience. And, um, we thought that with that, you know,
that we come back this year and try to sell this thing. And still like,
there was just no traction. Really? I don't get it. I don't get it either.
You guys pitched it during the beginning of the pandemic. No way, but Oh yeah.
It doesn't matter when we pitch it. There's something that's just not,
I don't know what it is with Hollywood man. It's it's mind boggling to me. Um,
it really is. And it hurts my feelings. Yeah. It hurts my feelings.
That's the only thing. And I, and I say hurts my feelings because it's like,
cause I know that we are amazing together individually
and together, we're enormous funny together. And we deserve it.
Like, you know what I mean? And it's, and it's like,
I guess we have to pay for it ourselves again. It's like,
that's the kind of world we live in. Why? Yeah.
Why I don't mind doing it and I will. It's going to happen. Yeah. But whatever,
man. it, dude. No, I don't. I'm not letting it go because,
because by talking about it too, because believe it or not, you know,
I know a lot of people that are in the business that are like in, you know,
the studio and the, and the network sides of things that listen to this,
you know? And so they do no, but that,
that, that's what you call a humblebrag. No,
I'm not saying no because I've humbly bragged about no,
but I've been at T we're CA cable reads and an executive come after me after
the, you know, may go Nosotras papaya or, or, or they'll say, you know, uh,
a catchphrase from tiger Valley. Right? So it's like, man, you, no,
that's not what I'm saying. I'm good telling you at that.
Does it tell you that we get it movies?
Maybe you can make your case on here that we're trying to make a case on here.
That's basically what I'm saying. That everything needs to be defensive.
Not everything has to be a twist. You're the only one that's doing it. I think.
Nope. There's the jury's over there and you're convincing them.
You're not guilty, judge.
How am I doing? Am I the one that no, I will say you're moving a lot.
He's had his legs in the same position the whole time. That's all I observed.
So you're saying that my body language is in the defensive moving a lot.
I'm just a high energy kind of a guy. He can't be the first to, to attack you.
I'm not attacking you.
He's been placing his proudest shoe in front of me camera this whole time.
Why didn't you wear the golden goose? Why didn't you wear my golden goose,
Gucci glasses. Those are dope. My shoes match my jacket. Yeah.
So, um, what I'm saying is that I think that we should still fight for the,
you know, I, yeah, man, I even told Holly I'm willing to put up money for it.
Yeah. And just make it, you know, I still get a little, you know,
but I think this is a part of just being in a up business that we're
in. Yeah. And the kind of people that we are, you know, I,
there is a layer of sense of sensitivity that I have. Right. So it's like.